das hier sind Bilder von eben gerade von
der Grenze Ägyptens in den
Gazastreifen erstmals seit kriegsbegn im
Nahen Osten vor zwei Wochen sind
Hilfslieferungen auf dem Weg in den
gaserstreifen die Vereinten Nationen
haben das im Überblick nach tagelangen
Verhandlungen für die Menschen in Gaza
herzlich willkommen zu dieser Phönix
Sondersendung meine Damen und Herren
schön dass Sie da sind mehr als 200 LKW
warten offenbar vor dem Grenz Übergang
raffach zwischen Ägypten und dem
gazerastreifen mit über 3000 Tonnen
humanitären Hilfsmitteln für Gaza 20 20
LKW sollen jetzt rüberkommen an diesem
Samstag nachdem die Hamas zwei Geiseln
us-bürgerinnen freigelassen hat aber wie
lange die Grenze für wie viele Laster
offen bleiben soll für die
Hilfslieferung ist noch völlig unklar
und Menschen dürfen auf jeden Fall auch
weiterhin nicht den Übergang nach
nehmen am Morgen konnten erste
Hilfslieferungen in den von Israel
abgeriegelten Gazastreifen gebracht
werden der Hilfsorganisation roter
Halbmond zufolge sollen die Lastwagen
vor allem mit Arznei und Nahrungsmitteln
beladen sein laut
Weltgesundheitsorganisation stehen 170
Lastwagen mit humanitären
Versorgungsgütern bereit um den zwischen
Ägypten und dem gaserastreifen liegenden
Grenzübergang raffach zu
überqueren in der Nacht und in den
frühen genstunden setzte die israelische
Luftwaffe ihre Angriffe auf Ziele im
Gazastreifen fort Stellungen und
kommandoeinrichtungen der islamistischen
Hamas wurden laut israelischenem Militär
zerstört palästinensische Medien
berichten von mehreren Toten und V
letzten eine positive Nachricht aus der
Nacht war die Freilassung zweier
US-Amerikaner aus der Geiselhaft im
Gasastreifen Bilder von der
radikalislamischen Hamas an der Grenze
zum Gazastreifen übernahm das
israelische Militär dann die beiden
Frauen Judit ranan und ihre 17-jährige
Tochter waren beim Angriff der Hamas
Terroristen auf Israel am 7 Oktober aus
einem kibutz verschleppt worden nach
ihrer Freilassung telefonierten sie mit
US-Präsident
Biden in den USA zeigt sich der Vater
der Familie
überglücklich ich habe heute früh mit
meiner Tochter gesprochen sie klingt
sehr gut sie sieht sehr gut aus
Präsident Biden dankte dem golfstadt
Qatar für die Unterstützung auch Ägypten
soll vermittelt
haben ja und Anthony Blinken der
Außenminister der Amerikaner der hat
sich gestern Abend noch geäußert zu der
Freilassung der zwei
usbürgerinnen und auch zu den
Hilfslieferungen zwei amerikanische
Bürger die seit dem 7 oktober in der
Gewalt der Hamas waren sind freigelassen
worden
sie befinden sich jetzt in Sicherheit in
Israel in den Händen der dortigen
Behörden und wir gehen davon aus dass
ein Vertreter der US Botschaft sie
demnächst trifft damit sie in den
nächsten Stunden jegliche Unterstützung
bekommen und wir wollen sie natürlich
wieder zusammenführen mit ihren
Angehörigen wir teilen die Erleichterung
ihrer Angehörigen aber es gibt noch Zeh
weitere Amerikaner von denen wir nichts
wissen
wir wissen einige von ihnen sind Geiseln
der Hamas zusammen mit etwa 200 anderen
Geiseln die in Gaza festgehalten werden
männ na
Frauen Jungs und Mädchen ältere Menschen
aus vielen Ländern jeder einzelne von
ihnen sollte freigelassen
werden seit Beginn dieser Krise hat der
Präsident klar gemacht dass alles tun
wird um darauf hinzuwirken dass alle
Geiseln freigelassen werden während
meiner Reise in die Region habe ich das
noch mal klar gemacht wie wichtig es ist
für die USA und habe versucht Einfluss
zu nehmen auf unsere Partner auf eine
Freilassung hinzuwirken wir haben
unermütlich mit unseren Partner
gearbeitet ich kann jetzt hier nicht
öffentlich über dieil sprechen das
werden Sie verstehen aber wir fordern
alle auf
die Geiseln freizulassen und auch
sicheres
Geleit zu geben für die amerikanischen
Bürger die noch in Gaza sind ich darf in
diesem Zusammenhang der Regierung von
Qatar herzlich danken für ihre wichtige
Unterstützung als ich in der letzten
Woche vor Ort war habe ich mit
Angehörigen der gehalten gesprochen
Präsident beiden hat ja auch mit
Angehörigen gesprochen und man kann kaum
beschreiben wie verzweif
diese Menschen sind weil sie gar nicht
wissen was mit ihren Angehörigen
passiert wir werden uns einsetzen
unermütlich für Ihre Sicherheit keine
Familie wo auch immer sie lebt sollte
dieses durchmachen müssen wenn ich mit
den Angehörigen spreche wie auch der
Präsident dann sagen wir ihn immer
wieder die amerikanische Regierung wird
jeden Tag alles tun um auf die
Freilassung hinzuwirken und ihre
Angehörigen nach Hause zu bringen ich
gebe Ihnen das feierliche Versprechen
dass wir das auch weiterhin tun werden
wir werden alles versuchen uns für diese
Angehörigen einzusetzen ich kann jetzt
nichts sagen zu diesen beiden
freigelassenen Geisen wie es Ihnen geht
also es geht ja auch um den Schutz Ihrer
Privatsphäre außerdem konnten wir ja
noch nicht mit ihnen sprechen also unser
Team vor Ort wird sich dann mit Ihnen
ins Benehmen setzen und die müssen
natürlich dann auch mit ihrer Familie
wieder zusammengeführt wird und ich
denke den nächsten Stunden und Tagen
wird sich da noch einiges ergeben aber
im Augenblick kann ich dazu nicht mehr
sagen ich kann auch nicht mehr zu sagen
wie es den Amerikanern geht die noch in
den Händen der
hamasse sind was den Grenzübergang Rafa
anbelangt sie wissen ja wir waren in der
letzten Woche zusammen auch in
Ägypten und insofern ist es einfach
wichtig das war eine meiner obersten
Prioritäten dafür zu sorgen dass die hil
Güter nach Gaza gelangen wir haben mit
der Regierung Israels und Ägyptens
zusammengearbeitet um darauf hinzuwirken
und wir haben uns geeinigt dass wir
einen Plan erstellen werden um die
Hilfsgüter nach Gaza zu bringen als
Präsident Biden in Israel war hat er das
noch mal unterstrichen auch in seinem
Gespräch mit Präsident Asisi dann haben
wir zusammen mit dem Botschafter vor Ort
mit der UN UNO mit Ägypten und mit
Israel eng
zusammengearbeitet und ich gehe davon
aus dass diese Hilfsgüter bald über die
Grenze gehen
werden wir versuchen für Sie meine Damen
und Herren ja jeden Tag das gesamte Bild
zu einem Thema im Blick zu haben und
dazu gehören heute auch die Aussagen des
israelischen armeesprechers Daniel
hagari der sagt heute morgen dass ein
Fünftel aller Raketen der letzten 24
Stunden aus dem
gazerastreifen durch Israels
Abwehrsystem wieder auf der gazaeite
gelandet sein und dort wohl auch
Menschen also Palästinenser innen
getötet hätten ob das nur Propaganda ist
oder ein weiteres bisher fehlendes und
dann ja wichtiges informationsdetail das
können wir nicht überprüfen wollen Ihnen
aber die genauen Aussagen zeigen denn
insgesamt so sagt er sollen es 550
Raketen sein seit Kriegsbeginn vor zwe
Wochen die von Palästinensern abgefeuert
auf Gaza Gebiet gelandet sein
guten
Tag wir sind am 15 Tag des Krieges
seitdem das angefangen
hat im Süden in Gazastreifen attackieren
wir
weiter die Terrororganisation
Hammers wir werden das
Weitermachen gerade gegen Ziele die
vielleicht nachher unsere
bodenofensive ein Problem sein
kön 24 Stunden ein fünften alle raketten
sind im gaserstreifen gelandet das heißt
alles was aus den Gaser Streifen
abgefeuert wird ein fünft davon landet
dort und das bringt
auch Bürger eigene Bürger werden
umgebracht und das tun sie ohne
skruppel die humanitäre Lage im
gaserstreifen ist unter
Kontrolle und wir geben Bewohner von
Gazastreifen alles in dem Sinne
das was sie humanitär brauchen aber wir
sagen Ihnen sie möchten und müssen
trotzdem nach Süden gehen in Richtung
Süden gerade anläsig der neuen Phasen
des Krieges bis jetzt ca 700 000
Bewohner gingen schon nach
Süden in Richtung Süden des
Gazastreifens bitte machen Sie es auch
weiter
die politische Führung hat zugelassen
dass Wasser und Lebensmittel und
Medikamente kamen kein Öl kam rein ich
wiederhole kein Öl kam kam rein im
Norden wir haben letzten Stunden weiter
Stellungen von hiszbullah
attackiert alle
diese Ortschaften die wir bombardiert
haben sind für uns eine strategische
Bedrohung und von dort wurde auf uns
auch abgefeuert und daher haben wir das
auch gemacht unsere Botschaft im Norden
ist relativ klar wer wird versuchen zu
uns
reinzudringen wird
umgebracht bis jetzt haben wir an die
Familie von
307 gefallen von den israelischen
Streitkräften und 210
verschleppten
und ich will diese Zahl noch mal
erklären also wir untersuchen die ganze
Zeit wer die Leute sind und wir müssen
immer genau wissen ob die Person
wirklich die Person ist und wenn wir
eine Zeichen haben dass wirklich die
Person ist die Person dann können wir
erst dann die Familie
benachrichtigen um zu sagen dass die
Person entweder entführt oder
verschleppt
ist entführt oder äh
man nicht weiß wo die
sind unser Ziel ist alle verschleppten
nach Hause zurückzubringen zu uns nach
Israel und so werden wir es auch weiter
machen im
Hinterland machen wir
unsere quasi Routine des Krieges weiter
und ich wende an euch die bewohn stat
Israel ihr macht das sehr gut bitte
macht das so
weiter füren einen Krieg aber wir müssen
trotzdem eine ruhige Routine haben und
wir müssen sehr diszipliniert sein und
so machen wir es auch
weiter ich hoffe dass der Sabbat hier
ruhig sein wird vielen
Dank es ist ein intensiver Samstag an
dem sich vieles tut das kriegen sie
schon mit meine Damen und Herren denn
auch in Kairo geht etwas von Statten das
am Ende nicht ganz unwichtig sein könnte
der sogenannte kair peace ein
Friedensgipfel mit staatenlenkern von 31
Staaten großer Empfang dort durch den
ägyptischen Präsidenten al Sisi viele
arabische Staaten sind dabei aber auch
der euratschef Charles Michelle den wir
eben schon gesehen haben bis hin zu der
deutschen Außenministerin Anna Lena
berbock Israel ist nach eigenen Angaben
nicht eingeladen auch die USA oder Iran
sind
dabei sprechen wir da gerne drüber über
den Friedensgipfel aber zuerst mal über
die Hilfslieferungen für Gaza mit
unserer Korrespondentin in Kairo Anna
Feist Frau Feist was wissen Sie noch
mehr über diese Hilfslieferungen die
heute also beginnen sollten und offenbar
begonnen
haben ja es sollen 20 LKW sein die heute
früh die Grenze passier haben das
konnten wir hier im staatlichen
Fernsehen live mitverfolgen das ganze
wurde gestreamt auf diesen 20 LKW soll
sich Wasser befinden es soll sich Essen
befinden es soll sich Medizin befinden
was wir hier mitbekommen haben über eben
diese Live Übertragung ist wie diese LKW
reinfahren die Grenze Raffa passieren
und auf palästinensischer Seite warten
leere LKW und diese leeren LKW werden
dann beladen mit den ägyptischen LKW und
bringen dann die Güter weiter in die
Grenze das klingt ja nach einem relativ
komplexen Prozess also nicht nur die
Verhandlung der letzten Tage sondern
auch das jetzt wie lange dauert das und
was ist eigentlich mit den anderen über
offenbar dann ja 180 oder 200 Lastwagen
die da mit vielen Taus Tonnen
Hilfsgütern weiterhin
warten ja dazu haben wir bisher hier
keine Information wir haben hier auch
keine Informationen darüber was mit den
Menschen mit westlicher ja
Staatsbürgerschaft passiert die sich
derzeit in Gaza aufhalten sollen und die
ja seit Tagen an der Grenze und in einer
un-schule die sich direkt an der Grenze
befindet ausharren da warten auch wir
auf Information was allerdings sein
könnte ist dadurch dass diese
Grenzöffnung heute sozusagen
orchestriert passiert parallel zu dem
Friedensgipfel den sie ja eben bereits
angesprochen haben wäre es nicht
verwunderlich dass jetzt im Rahmen
dieses friedengipsels im Rahmen dieser
dieser livestreamings die hier von der
Grenze passieren eben auch Menschen noch
von palästinensischer Seite nach Ägypten
durchgelassen werden das wollte ich
gerade noch mal fragen das ja ein
wichtiger Punkt bevor wir dann über den
Friedensgipfel sprechen also Menschen
dürfen weiterhin aus dem gazerastreifen
nicht rüber also die Grenze ist auch
nicht offen inwiefern gibt's dort auch
eine Diskussion bei ihnen in Ägypten
oder inwiefern könnte das jetzt sie
haben gesagt im Rahmen dieses Gipfels in
größerem Maße kommen oder wären das dann
nur vereinzelte oder im Zweifel auch nur
welche die tatsächlich einen Fremden
Pass
haben also was wir gehört haben von dem
grenzmanager auf palästinensischer Seite
bei dem hatten wir am Vormittag noch mal
nachgefragt der sagte heute ist nicht zu
erwarten dass Menschen mit westlicher
Staatsbürgerschaft passieren dürfen
die weiteren Informationen die wir haben
sind nach wie vor wie in sind die
gleichen geblieben ägypten will auf gar
keinen Fall Zivilisten Flüchtlinge aus
Gaza aufnehmen sie sag einerseits würde
es bedeutet dass die palästinensische
Sache eliminiert würde andererseits
fürchtet man natürlich auch hier um die
nationale Sicherheit man fürchtet dass
unter den Flüchtlingen Terroristen hier
nach Ägypten ins Land kommen können mhm
dann gucken wir auf den Friedensgipfel
den sie ja schon angesprochen haben was
kann der aus ihrer Sicht noch bringen
außer dass vielleicht vereinzelte
Westler mit westlichem Pass die sich im
gaserstreifen befinden möglicherweise in
den nächsten Tagen oder heute wie Sie
sagten vielleicht doch noch rüber kenen
ja also ein paar Beobachtung
Beobachtungen dazu der Gipfel läuft ja
seit 11 Uhr der ägyptische Präsident hat
drei Ziele gesetzt das erste Ziel
humanitäre Hilfen weiter konkretisieren
das zweite Ziel jetzt gucke ich einmal
auf meinen Zettel eine Waffenruhe eine
Feuerpause vereinbaren das dritte Ziel
eine skizzieren wie eine
Zweistaatenlösung aussehen könnte und
anwesend auf diesem Gipfel ist auch der
Palästinenserführer Mahmud Abbas Mahmud
Abbas war sehr klar in seiner Aussage
dass die Palästinenser Ihr Land nicht
verlassen werden dass sie da bleiben
würden und eine weitere Beobachtung
spannenderweise kam ausgerechnet von
jetzt dem saudi-arabischen Außenminister
sehr gemilderte Töne also es war die
Hetze die viele arabischen Staatsführer
auf diesem Gipfel bisher gegenüber
Israel Betrieben ähm kam von saudischer
Seite nicht dass dieser Friedensgipfel
jetzt tatsächlich Frieden bringt ist
sehr unwahrscheinlich auch aus dem Grund
weil drei ganz wichtige Player fehlen es
fehlt Israel die so sagen sie nicht
eingeladen wurden es fehlt der Iran und
es fehlt aber auch ein hochrangiger
Politiker aus Amerika und Amerika
versteht sich als schutzmach Israels der
Iran versteht sich als Verbündete der
Hamas und dadurch dass nun eben diese
drei ganz wichtigen Konfliktparteien
nicht dabei S ist nicht zu erwarten dass
jetzt hier der große Frieden beschlossen
werden kann da werden wir in dieser
Sendung auch gleich noch mal drüber
sprechen zum Abschluss der Blick auch in
das Land noch mal in dem sie ja auch
jetzt gerade sind nach Ägypten was
bedeutet dieses Event dieser
Friedensgipfel für den ägyptischen
Präsidenten als Sisi den wir auch gleich
noch mal hören
werden ja für Ägypten ist das eine tolle
Möglichkeit zurück auf die große
politische Weltbühne zu kommen im Sommer
gab es ja die Friedensverhandlungen
zwischen Israel und Saudi-Arabien das
hatte Ägypten die ja eigentlich der
große Vermittler in der Region waren ein
bisschen ins Abseits gedrängt und seit
dem Krieg also seitdem die Hamas die
Terrororganisation Israel überfallen hat
ist Ägypten zurück in seiner neuen alten
Rolle als Vermittler und
Ägypten profitiert in diesen Tagen
diplomatisch sehr von dem Krieg vielen
Dank Anna Feist für die Einschätzungen
und Einordnung von in live aus
Ciro und dann gucken wir auf den
ägyptischen Präsidenten als S habe ich
schon angesprochen den Gastgeber dieses
Cairo summit for peace und das was er
vor diesem Gipfel gesagt hat
Ägypten verurteilt das Töten von jedem
Zivilisten
gleichzeitig wundern wir uns
sehr
zuschaut wie eine menschliche
Tragödie und diese
Katastrophe in der 2,5 Millionen
Menschen in Palästina in Gaza eine
kollektive
Bestrafung
durchmachen sie werden gesperrt
verhungert und unter großem
Druck
gesetzt damit sie ihre Häuser mit Gewalt
verlassen durch Aktivitäten die die die
zivilisierte Welt
ablehnt die das internationale Gesetz
formte und vor allem das menschliche
Gesetz die Abkommen
abschließ damit diese Verbrechen nicht
meh nicht mehr sich nicht mer
wiederholen deshalb rufen wir
auf das palätinensische
Volk und die Zivilisten
die gesperrten Menschen in Menschen zu
helfen Ägypten hat sich bemüht
humanitäre Hilfen zu leisten für
Menschen in
Gaza wir haben noch nie wir haben nie
den den ges den Grenzübergang Gaza
geschlossen jedoch war die Arbeit
dort unmöglich weil is auf die
palästinensische Seite bombardiert hatte
auf diesem Grunde habe ich mit den
amerikanischen Präsidenten vereinbart
dass der Grenzübergang dauerhaft offen
bleibt und mit Unterstützung und
Abstimmung mit UNO undroh und
palätinischen Roten Halbmond
Organisation organisiert wird Ziel war
dass die Bewohner in Gaza humanitäre
Hilfe
bekommen
die Welt muss doch ablehnen dass die
Menschen mit Gewalt ihre Häuser
verlassen
Ägypten lehnt kategorisch ab dass die
palätinenser ihre Häuser in G durch
Gewalt verlassen
und
und und vertrieben werden und dass sie
nach dem ägyptischen Sinai vertrieben
werden
das bedeutet nicht nichts anderes als
dass der palästinische Konflikt beendet
wird und der Traum der Palästinenser auf
ein eigenes Land zu haben W dadurch in
Ken
gesetzt man macht einen fatalen Fehler
zu denken dass die Palästinenser ihr
Land verlassen
werden ja sprechen wir über diesen Krieg
mit Christin Hellberg viele viele Jahre
selbst im nahen Ost gelebte und
Politikwissenschaftlerin und Autorin
hallo frauberg hallo Herr Bauer frauberg
also die beginnen wir mal mit den
Hilfslieferungen das aktuellste von
heute Morgen wie viel sind diese 20
Laster die es jetzt offenbar sein sollen
die dann hoffentlich auch offenbar eben
Hilfslieferungen bringen werden für Gase
wie viel sind die aus ihrer Sicht Wert
nun 20 Lastwagen mit medizinischen
Gütern Lebens Mitteln und Trinkwasser
sind eine lächerliche Menge natürlich
angesichts der Not in Gaza was es
braucht wäre eine kontinuierliche
Versorgung jetzt was der Präsident S
auch angekündigt hat dass eigentlich
dieser Grenzübergang rafach geöffnet
bleiben soll dasd Welternährungsprogramm
der Vereinten Nationen spricht ja davon
dass man alleine jeden Tag 100 Lkw
bräuchte um die Menschen mit
Nahrungsmitteln zu versorgen und was
ganz dringend bebraucht wird ist ja der
Treibstoff in Gasa für die
Stromversorgung für die
Wasseraufbereitung um eben auch
Krankenhäuser weiterhin zu betreiben und
es gibt immer wieder Einschränkungen was
die Menge betrifft es gibt
Einschränkungen was die Art der Güter
betrifft auch die Orte wohin sie
geliefert werden und das wird ja auch
kritisiert von internationalen
humanitären Organisationen auch von den
Vereinten Nationen die eben sagen das
humanitäre Völkerrecht verpflichtet alle
Parteien eines Konfliktes da
ungehinderten Zugang zu ermöglichen und
da wir nicht mit einem Waffenstillstand
rechnen können wäre ein humanitärer
Korridor eine wichtige Forderungen in
dem dann eben Hilfslieferungen ihre
Trans Porter durchschleusen können dort
dürfen sie nicht bombardiert werden und
diese internationalen Organisation
müssten dann die humanitären Güter
Vorort in Ruhe verteilen können Israel
möchte natürlich verhindern dass die
Hilfe bei der Hamas landet auch das
müsste sichergestellt werden mit
entsprechenden internationalen Partnern
auf der palästinensischen Seite und es
ist ja offenbar auch völlig unklar wie
viel z.B eben auch Benzin geliefert wird
tatsächlich weil Israel ja sagt das
könnte eben auch für nichtthumanitäre
Zwecke dann durch die Hamas missbraucht
werden
genau auf der anderen Seite ist aber der
Treibstoff ebeno entscheidend auch für
die humanitäre Lage der Menschen in Gaza
gucken mal zu dem auf das zweite Thema
dieses morgens auch nach dem gestrigen
Abend nämlich die Freilassung für zwei
US-Amerikanerinnen inwiefern ist das
wofür aus ihrer Sicht ein Zeichen nun
zunächst mal ist diese Freilassung der
amerikanischen Mutter und ihre Tochter
natürlich ein Zeichen der Hoffnung für
alle Angehörigen von Geiseln die sich
immer noch in den Händen der
Terrororganisation Hamas befinden es ist
aber auch ein Zeichen dafür dass
diplomatische Beziehungen mit der Hamas
und Bemühungen mit der Hamas in diesem
Falle tatsächlich konkrete Ergebnisse
bringen können das hat in diesem Fall
Katar ausgehandelt und es zeigt eben
auch dass Verhandlungen mit der
politischen Führung der Hamas im Ausland
einen Effekt haben auf das was in Gaza
passiert obwohl gleichzeitig ja die
militärischen Entscheidungen dieser
Terrororganisation in Gaza und für Gaza
ziemlich autonom getroffen werden und
die Hamas sendet da eine klare Botschaft
man möchte eben auch als politischer
Akteur wahrgenommen werden mit dem man
verhandeln kann hamasvertreter haben ja
im Zuge dieser geiselname davon
gesprochen dass sie jetzt aus
humanitären Gründen eben diese Mutter
und die Tochter freigelassen haben sie
haben auch mal erwähnt dass die
ausländischen Geiseln als Gäste
betrachtet würden aus ihrer Sicht
insofern gibt es also jetzt eine
wachsende Hoffnung dass weitere Geiseln
freiommen können vor allem Kinder Mütter
ältere Menschen und die Länder die
diplomatische Kontakt haben mit der
Hamas die sitzen eben gerade auch alle
in Kairo zusammen nämlich Katar Ägypten
und die Türkei und es ist da eben die
Hoffnung dass die sich womöglich auch
untereinander etwas besser noch
absprechen und jetzt nicht gegenseitig
versuchen sich da den Einfluss auf die
Hamas streitig zu machen und jeweils
erst derjenige Akteur daz stehen der
besonders viele Geiseln da frei beekommt
also mehr Koordination unter diesen
Ländern wäre natürlich wünschenswert mit
Bezug auf die Geiseln fr da sprechen wir
gleich noch mal weiter drüber weil sie
haben ja die Verhandlung angesprochen
übrigens die Geiseln als Gäste zu
bezeichnen ich würde sagen diese
Sichtweite hat die Hamas Solitär in der
Welt aber dann gucken wir doch gerne
noch mal auf diesen Friedensgipfel der
heute eben auch in Kairo stattfindet und
sprechen darüber aber hören vorher noch
mal die deutsche bundesaußenministerin
annaalena berbock eben gerade
tatsächlich so gesagt auf diesem
Friedensgipfel Israel ein israelischer
Vater mit rotgeintten Augen
klagt dass seine Frau und seine Tochter
brutal von Hamas Terroristen entführt
wurden eine Mutter in Gaza ist völlig
verzweifelt weil sie kein Trinkwasser
für ihr kleines Baby findet und sie hat
Angst dass die Gewalt noch mehr Opfer
für andere Familienangehörige fordert
eine Familie im Libanon die sich Sorge
machte dass die Gewalt askkalieren
könnte und ihr Land erreichen könnte
überall in der Region sehen wir
unendliches Leid und Angst lassen Sie
mich es ganz klar sagen es steht außer
Zweifel alle leben von Zivilisten zählen
gleichermaßen und lassen sie mir auch
mich auch klar sagen die Ursache für das
Leid dieser letzten
Wochen das Leid das uns hier
zusammenbringt das Leid der Mutter und
der Mädchen all das hat einen Namen es
war die Hamas die am 7 Oktober
fürchterlichen Terror gegen Israel
beging und schänliche Verbrechen verübt
hat wie jedes andere Land in der Welt
hat Israel das Recht sich selbst zu
verteidigen und sein Volk gegen diesen
Terror zu verteidigen im Rahmen des
Völkerrechtes deshalb steht die deutsche
Regierung fest
zu Israel für Deutschland ist die
Sicherheit des Staates Israel nicht
verhandelbar was auch klar ist ist dass
die Täter dieses Terrors nicht für die
Menschen in Palästina sprechen sie
sprechen nur für sich
selbst sie sprechen die Sprache des
Terrors die palästinensischen Mütter und
Väter in
Gaza die trwer für ihre Kinder finden
die sprechen nicht die Sprache des
Terrors ihre Brüder und Schwestern im
westjordalan in Jordanien oder im
Libanon die Angst haben vor einer
regionalen Eskalation die sprechen nicht
diese Sprache des Terrors wir hier in
diesem Saal sprechen diese Sprache auch
nicht wir sprechen die Sprache des
Völkerrechtes der Humanität und der
friedlichen Koexistenz
das eint uns in diesem Sinne appelliere
ich an alle aufzustehen gegen den
Terrorismus ich appelliere an alle einen
Unterschied zu machen zwischen den
Terroristen und der Zivilbevölkerung und
das zu jeder Zeit und ich appelliere an
alle nicht die Flammen des Hasses weiter
zu befördern denn genau das will Hamas
und die
spansoren sie wollen eine weitere
regionale Eskalation und sie wollen uns
Spalten die Pläne der Terroristen dürfen
nicht aufgeben gehen deshalb muss der
Kampf gegen hamase mit größt
möglicher Achtung der humanitären Lage
ausgeführt werden für die
unschuldigen Frauen Kinder und Männer in
Gaza deshalb müssen wir jetzt gemeinsam
unsere anstrengen vertiefen um die
Bedürftigsten zu unterstützen
Deutschland hat seine humanitäre Hilfe
für Gaza um 50 Millionen Euro
aufgestockt wir fordern alle auf auch
die Länder der Region sich dieser Sache
anzuschließen und einige haben das ja
auch schon angekündigt es ist von
entscheidender Bedeutung dass die
humanitären Hilfsgüter
schneller nach Gaza gelangen und es ist
gut dass sie jetzt über den
Grenzübergang Rafa dort gelang ich darf
mich bei der ägyptischen Regierung bei
den amerikanischen Partnern und bei der
UNO herzlich für Ihre Anstrengung in
diesem Sinne bedanken aber wir wissen
wir brauchen noch mehr Hilfe um das
Leiden zu mildern und ich freue mich
dass hier in diesem Saal wir uns einig
sind dass letztlich die Region einen
neuen Friedensprozess
braucht der beiden gestattet den
israelern Israelis und den
Palästinensern friedlich und sicher
Seite an Seite zu leben in zwei
unabhängigen
Staaten das klingt vielleicht heute noch
weit weg aber nur eine gerechte und
dauerhafte Lösung würde auch letztlich
die Niederlage von Hamas und ihren
Drehbuch besiegen denn
sie wendet sich gegen die Menschlichkeit
und gegen diplomasie die entführten
israelischen Kinder die Mutter in Gaza
die Familien im Libanon die brauchen uns
sie brauchen uns
jetzt sie brauchen uns die
internationale Gemeinschaft und wir
müssen die Sprache der Humanität
sprechen
schukan am Ende das schukran das danke
auf Arabisch von annalina
berbock also Frau helellberg dieser
Friedensgipfel in Ciro den sie eben
schon angtiast haben am heutigen Tage
was kann der aus ihrer Sicht dann
tatsächlich bringen nun Friedensgipfel
ist natürlich ein viel zu großes Wort
wir haben gerade gehört Annalena berbock
sagt natürlich auch man braucht
langfristig einen neuen eine neue
Verhandlungslösung man braucht einen
eine Lösung einen Friedensprozess der in
einer zwei staatenlösung münden sollte
das ist aber gerade noch nicht der
Moment dafür ich denke tatsächlich geht
es vor allem bei diesem Treffen gerade
in Cairo darum dass es eine ein dass
eine einheitliche Position innerhalb der
Region erstmal gefunden wird also
einerseits Unterstützung für die
Palästinenser zu bekräftigen vor allem
auch um die Wut und den Hass einzuhegen
der sich ja auf den Straßen von Beirut
von Aman in Ciro auch in Istanbul
entläht und die Machthaber all jener
Länder die diplomatische Beziehungen mit
Israel unterhalten die geraten ja unter
wachsenden Druck ihrer eigenen
Bevölkerung die natürlich entsetzt ist
über diese Bombardierung und Belagerung
des
gasastreifens Jordanien die Türkei genau
diese Länder und da geht jetzt erstmal
darum Solidarität zu zeigen und es ist
eben einfach noch nicht der Moment für
ein ganz umfassendes Gipfeltreffen mhm
ähm die das sind ja vor allem eben die
Länder Türkei Qatar und Ägypten die eben
intensive Verbindungen zur Hamas
weiterhin haben was kann was muss deren
Aufgabe aus ihrer Sicht jetzt
sein nun deren Aufgabe besteht vor allem
darin dass sie sich koordinieren dass
sie auf die hammas einwirken dass
erstens mal die mit dem Fokus auf die
ausländischen geile natürlich dass die
freikommen aus dem gaserastreifen dass
auch die Möglichkeit besteht dass diese
1000 Menschen mit ausländischen Pass
herausgelassen werden aus dem
Gazastreifen äh einigkeit herrscht
natürlich in Ciro auch dies auch in in
Sachen humanitäre Hilfe die ausgeweitet
werden muss es geht darum einen
Waffenstillstand herbeizuführen an Ende
der Kämpfe und es besteht übrigens auch
große Einigkeit darüber dass die
Bevölkerung des Gazastreifens nicht
vertrieben werden kann in ein anderes
Land z.B Ägypten der palästinensische
Präsident Abbas sprach ja dann von einer
drohenden zweiten nabaar also in
Anlehnung an nabaar die Katastrophe von
1948 wo mehr als 750.000 Palästinenser
im Zuge der Staatsgründung Israels
vertrieben wurden man braucht also eine
langfristige Lösung in Gaza auch das ist
klar Israel der israelische
Verteidigungsminister hat gestern schon
klar gesagt dass Israel in Zukunft keine
Verantwortung mehr übernehmen möchte für
das Leben in Gasastreifen und da stellt
sich natürlich die Frage wer soll das
tun da braucht es mit Sicherheit mehr
internationales Engagement das kann man
jetzt nicht alleine Ägypten überlassen
in der Zukunft mhm Frau hberg da
sprechen wir gleich noch mal drüber da
haben wir vielleicht auch noch mal
aktuelle Bilder vom Übergang in Raffa
und wir schauen hier sehen wir das auch
das ist von eben gerade da sehen wir
also tatsächlich LKWs die den
Grenzübergang offenbar hier auch auf
palästinensisches Gebiet in den Gaza
strereifen wollte ich sagen überquert
haben das glaube ich aber nicht weil ich
sehe da unten die ganzen Medien und das
sieht mir nicht alles nach ich kann es
ehrlich gesagt Ihnen nicht sagen meine
Damen und Herren welche Seite wir hier
sehen es ist auf jeden Fall der
Grenzübergang rafach und wir sehen dass
LKW auf jeden Fall sich bewegen es sind
einige die wir da gesehen haben in den
letzten zwei Stunden gucken wir noch mal
bevor wir gleich noch mal weiter
diskutieren Frau Hellberg hören wir noch
mal auf zwei weitere die vielleicht ja
auch Mediatoren werden könnten in diesem
Konflikt in diesem Krieg den wir gerade
sehen nämlich einerseits
den Ratspräsident der Europäischen Union
Charles Michelle und andererseits den
Generalsekretär der Vereinten Nationen
Antonio gter
wir treffen uns im Herzen einer Region
die leidelt und nur einen Schritt vom
Abgrund entfernt ist eine Region wo wir
diese
herzzerreisenden Bilder menschlichen
Leidens immer wiedershen gestern war ich
am Grenzübergang
Raffa da habe
ich gesehen wie sich humanitäre Krise in
Echtzeit entwickelt auf der einen Seite
habe ich hunderte von Lastwagen gesehen
voller Nachschub und
Vorrede auf der anderen Seite der Grenze
das wissen wir aber gibt es 2 Millionen
Menschen die kein Wasser haben keinen
Treibstoff kein Strom und keine
abzneimittel Kinder Mütter kranke ältere
Mitbürger volle LKWs auf der einen Seite
leere mgen auf der anderen diese
Lastwagen müssen so schnell wie möglich
sich bewegen von Ägypten hin in den
Gazastreifen ein Konvoi mit 20 LKWs des
ägyptischen Roten Halbmond ist heute
losgefahren und ich bedanke mich bei
Ägypten für seine zentrale Rolle aber
die Menschen in Gaza brauchen sehr viel
mehr wir brauchen den stetigen Fluss von
Hilfsgüter nach Gaza in dem benötigten
Umfang und wir arbeiten nonstop mit
allen Beteiligten zusammen Exzellenz in
eins muss klar
sein das Leid der
palästinensischen Bevölkerung bewegt uns
und ihr
Bestreben ist auch legitim aber wir
dürfen auch nicht die umfassenden
Auswirkungen vergessen wir haben 56
Jahre lang Besatzung erlebt und ein Ende
ist noch nicht aber nichts kann
rechtfertigen dass die Hamas diesen
fürchterlichen Angriff auf israelische
Zivilisten begangen hat und
niemand kann rechtfertigen dass das
palästinensische Volk jetzt bestraft
wird wir müssen die
genferkonvention einhalten das heißt
Zivilisten müssen geschützt werden
Krankenhäuser dürfen nicht angegriffen
werden und andere Einrichtung exellenzen
unsere unmittbaren Ziele müssen klar
sein soforte und nachhaltige humanitäre
Hilfe für die Zivilisten in Gaza
sofortige Freilassung aller Geiseln und
sofortige Anstrengung um zu verhindern
dass die Gewalt sich nicht noch weiter
ausbreitet ich forder eine humanitäre
Waffenruhe Exzellenzen unsere
gemeinsamen Anstrengungen und
Ressourcen forlich es geht
darum die Bombardierung zu beenden aber
es geht darum eine realistische
Grundlage für den Frieden und für die
zwei
staatenlösung zu finden die Israelis
müssen sehen dass ihre legitimen
sicherheitsrechte und Bedürfnisse
umgesetzt werden und die Palästinenser
müssen sehen dass ihr Bestreben nach
einem unabhängigen Staat umgesetzt wird
auf der Grundlage von UNO Resolutionen
und internation
ist Zeit zu handeln Zeit diesen
fürchterlichen
Albtraum zu beenden und die Träume der
Kinder von Israel Palästina in der
Region und weltweit zu
verwirklichen wir verurteilen auf
schärfste den schändlichen
Terroranschlag der Hamas gegen Israel
und seine Bevölkerung und
wir assung der Geisel ohne Vorbehalt und
unverzüglich und ich möchte allen hier
am Tische danken die vermittelnd
eingegriffen haben damit eben die Geisen
freigelassen werden wir bekräftigen noch
einmal wie wichtig es ist die Zivilisten
zu schützen und auch zivile
Infrastrukturen immer überall und
jederzeit und wir bekräftigen das Recht
Israel auf Selbstverteidigung
dieses Recht muss ausgeübt werden im
einglang mit dem Völkerrecht und mit dem
humanitären
Völkerrecht wie geht es weiter uns
scheinen drei
Punkte
wichtig erstens geht es um die
Mobilisierung aller um den Zugang der
humanitären Hilfe zu ermöglichen damit
die schutzbedürftigsten Zugang zu
wasserstom neimittel und Treibstoff
haben und eine Belagerung totaler Art
widerspricht dem Völkerrecht insofern
bedanke ich mich bei allen die beteiligt
waren um Fortschritte hier in diesem
Bereich zu erzielen damit die Versorgung
mit grundlegenden Gütern sichergestellt
ist wir bedanken uns beim ägyptischen
Präsidenten dafür dass er sich
eingesetzt hat auch weiterhin h zu
ermöglichen die EU hat ja schon
angekündigt dass wir unsere
Unterstützung verdreifachen werden
zweitens geht es um Verantwortung jeder
trägt die
Verantwortung um eine regionale
Eskalation zu vermeiden den Konflikt zu
beenden und diesen Zyklus der Gewalt ein
Ende setzen ich denke das ist eine
Pflicht die wir alle haben und dann der
dritte
Punkt das ist die notwendig
alles zu tun um eine dauerhafte Lösung
zu
erreichen sprich eine zweist
staatenlösung da hat ja der hohvertreter
Borell eine Initiative ergriffen er war
mit mir gerade in New York und da geht
es natürlich darum dass wir uns auch
hier einbringen bei diesem
Friedensgipfel aber es geht vor allen
Dingen auch darum die palästinens
Behörde zu stärken die die legitimen
Bestrebungen des palästinensischen
Volkes vertritte das ist ein Konflikt
ein Drama das so viel Leid und Unglück
gestiftet hat ein Konflikt der überall
auf der Welt zu Polarisierung und
Spaltung und vielen Spannungen führt und
wir tragen die Verantwortung alles zu
tun um echte fort itte zu machen auf dem
Weg hin zu Frieden Stabilität und
Sicherheit da können sie auf die
Europäische Union zählen wir werden
unseren Beitrag leisten auch im Sinne
der Werte die wir überall vertreten
vielen Dank
schukran also Frau herber bleiben wir
bei dem was sie vorher gesagt haben und
der Frage eigentlich wer von diesen
Herren und Damen die wir hier auch bei
uns im Studio auf dem Monitor sehen
tatsächlich ein Interesse hat an einer
langfristigen Lösung Israel Palästina
oder zumindest erstmal für den
Gazastreifen wer wäre das denn
tatsächlich und wie könnte die Lösung
dann
aussehen ich denke dass alle Beteiligten
heute in Ciro eine Interesse daran haben
den Konflikt zwischen Palästinensern und
Israel ist langfristig zu lösen die
Nachbarländer ohnehin keiner möchte dass
dieser Konflikt sich ausbreitet also
eben vor allem aus der Sicht der
Machthaber in der Region und es ist auch
klar dass es natürlich kurzfristig jetzt
sehr wohl um die humanitäre Versorgung
gehen muss das ist schon richtig und
wichtig aber das ist natürlich noch kein
Konzept für Frieden und Sicherheit und
in der Vergangenheit haben wir eben
gesehen dass da einfach vor allem von
Seiten der USA aber auch von Seiten
Europas versucht wurde mit sehr viel
Geld einfach diesen konflit zu managen
man hat also in Gaza immer wieder
Infrastruktur aufgebaut man hat Schulen
gebaut Krankenhäuser
wasserausbereitungsanlagen finanziert
und dann kam der nächste Konflikt der
Raketenbeschuss durch die Hamas wieder
auf Israel israel hat mit
Raketenbeschuss reagiert und all das was
aufgebaut wurde mit europäischen Geldern
wurde wieder zerbombt das ist kein
Konzept und keine Lösung für die Zukunft
was es jetzt wirklich bräuchte ist mehr
internationales Engagement für das
Sicherheitsmanagement dieses
Gazastreifens und daran müssten sich
womöglich unsoldaten beteiligen daran
müssten sich eben womöglich auch die USA
und Europa beteiligen mit eigenen
ja also mit Menschen vor Ort die das
aktiv angehen es muss auch darum gehen
dass der Gazastreifen nicht wieder abger
wird das ist ja keine Perspektive für
die mehr als 2 Millionen Zivilisten dort
man muss das Gebiet entwickeln und eben
nicht einfach nur Geld bezahlen für die
Folgen dann dieses Konflikt immer wieder
aber Frau hberg das alles würde ja
voraussetzen dass erstmal in den
nächsten Wochen möglicherweise Monaten
haben wir gestern den israelischen
Verteidigungsminister ja schon gehört
erst einmal eine mögliche Bodenoffensive
Israels dann tatsächlich zustande kommt
und dann die Hamas von Israel komplett
zerstört wer
und erst danach könnte das Eintreten was
sie eben skizziert haben habe ich das
richtig
zusammengefasst das ist richtig wobei
die Hamas natürlich mit ihren
militärischen Infrastruktur in Gaza
jetzt zerstört werden kann und zerstört
werden muss aber das ist nicht das Ende
der Hamas ihre politische Führung sitzt
im Ausland und es wird ja aufgrund der
Bedingungen in Gazastreifen von denen
wir jetzt viel gehört haben immer wieder
eine Terrororganisation nachwachsen
angesichts der auswegosigkeit angesichts
der war nemung auch der jungen Menschen
in Gaza die Hälfte der Menschen sind
dort Minderjährige die haben auch nie
für die Hamas gewählt in den letzten
Jahren die letzten Wahlen in den
palästinensischen Gebieten haben 2006
stattgefunden damals hat die Hamas diese
Wahlen für sich entschieden das Problem
ist also dass wir dann auch wenn die
Hamas verschwunden ist andere Gruppen
haben werden die wenn nichts sich ändert
an der Situation in Gaza wieder Israel
angreifen werden und wieder die
Sicherheit Israels gefährden werden das
heißt es braucht schon langfristig ein
Konzept wie wir herauskommen aus dieser
ständigen Schleife der Gewalt und
Reaktion auf Gewalt mhm sehr spannend
danke für die Einordnung dann zum
Abschluss doch noch mal bitte der Blick
auf die Menschen also jetzt sage ich
Tage Wochen mögliche
Bodenoffensive Monate hat der
israelische Verteidigungsminister
gestern schon fast angekündigt was heißt
das denn für die Menschen in Gaza weil
zum Anfang unseres Gesprächs vor etwas
über 15 Minuten da haben sie gesagt 20
LKW das ist ja ein Tropfen auf dem
heißen Stein also wie soll denn über
Monate 2 Millionen Menschen überhaupt
überleben in dann ja wahrscheinlich dem
nur südlichen Teil des gasastreifens der
viel weniger noch weniger entwickelt
ist ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie
das gelingen soll wir haben ja auch
immer noch Hunderttausende die versuchen
sich in Sicherheit zu bringen Israel
fordert weiterhin die Menschen auf ihre
Häuser zu verlassen in Richtung Süden zu
gehen dort kommen erste Hilfslieferungen
an die viel zu gering sind also das
Drama und die Not der Menschen in Gaza
ist ungebrochen und für die kommt es
jetzt natürlich darauf an dass wir
wirklich eigentlich ein geregelte eine
geregelte Versorgung über diesen
Grenzübergang sicherstellen mit einer
täglichen Belieferung mit waren die
kontrolliert werden müssen natürlich
aber auch dafür muss es ein eine regul
eine Regulierung geben die einfach
routinemäßig jetzt anfängt zu
funktionieren es muss auch
sichergestellt sein dass die Menschen in
Gaza irgendwie bleiben können aber dort
sicher sind also die Forderung nach
Schutzzonen wenn es schon kein
Waffenstillstand geben wird und damit
ist nicht zu rechnen weil Israel ja ganz
klar sagt wir wollen diese
Bodenoffensive wir wollen die Hamas und
ihre Strukturen endgültig vernichten
wenn es also kein Waffenstillstand gibt
in nächster Zeit dann zumindest
Schutzzonen auf die man sich einigt in
den diese Zivilisten sicher sein können
vor dem beschutz der israelischen Armee
aber mittelfristig sehe ich für die
Menschen in Gaza nur weiterhin natürlich
sehr große Not insofern ist es wichtig
dass auch Leute wie Außenministerin Anna
Lena berbock bei aller Solidarität an
der Seite Israels aber auch der UN
Generalsekretär der EU-Ratspräsident
immer betonen dass für die israelischen
Angriffe die Verhältnismäßigkeit gilt
dass das abriegen 2 Millionen Menschen
eben keiner Form der Selbstverteidigung
mehr ist sondern dass da auch das
internationale Völkerrecht gilt auch dar
muss sich Israel immer wieder messen
lassen in seiner Reaktion auf diesen
Terror Christin Hellberg
Politikwissenschaftlerin und Autorin
lange im Nahen Osten gelebt vielen dank
Ihnen für die ganzen Einordnung hier bei
uns bei phöniix an diesem Samstag sehr
gerne so meine Damen und Herren mit dem
Thema übrigens beschäftigt sich auch der
internationale Frühschoppen morgen um 12
Uhr mit meiner Kollegin Eva Lindenau und
danach sehen wir uns auch noch mal
wieder mit einer Sondersendung um 13 Uhr
zu den aktuellen Ereignissen im Nahen
Osten und für 14R ist dann ja eine große
Friedenskundgebung auch in Solidarität
für Israel geplant in Berlin da werden
wir live hinschalten mit vielen
hochrangigen Mitgliedern der
Bundesregierung der Parteien und auch
der Bundespräsident soll dort dabei sein
also morgen 12 bis 16 Uhr wenn wir uns
intensiv damit beschäftigen und auch
hier im Programm heute denn jetzt folgt
hier das phöniix Plus Angriff auf Israel
Chronik des Terrors und es geht um die
ersten zwei Tage des Angriffs von der
Hamas auf Israel vor zwei Wochen bleiben
Sie gerne dran ich wünsche Ihnen ein
schönes Wochenende und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder bis dann
[Musik]
tschüss